cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
this is awesome
is the coolest thing ever from kob4 gun
owners rally in Old Town to protest
Public Health order you know they don't
want to just call it what it is the
headline should read gun owners defy
unconstitutional and criminal action by
Governor but uh maybe a little bit
strong for me but I I think that's the
fair the fair headline you've got this
video we've got Ford Fischer as well
many people openly carrying in defiance
of the governor's decree
good for them and the police are
basically backing away from this they're
saying that not that they're not going
to enforce it the statement from the
sheriff was was effectively that but it
was a little tepid so we'll see
they say more than 100 people openly
carried guns in Old Town as they
protested Governor Michelle Luan
grisham's recent controversial move on
Firearms you see they try very hard to
avoid calling what it is
we're not here to cause any issues we're
just here to you know express our
Amendment rights and you know we'll go
from there it was a rally against part
of grisham's Public Health Emergency on
gun violence specifically the part where
she banned carrying guns either through
open or concealed carry uh permits in
Bernalillo County and the City of
Albuquerque for 30 days no
constitutional right in my view
including my oath is intended to be
absolute there are restrictions on Free
Speech there are restrictions on freedom
that's what she said
my jaw dropped for a second amendment to
be to be suspended it it's
unconstitutional we got to put it that
way a lot of people feel that way said
Derek now here's the funny thing about
no no rights are absolute yes it means
due process of law not I hereby decree
you can't keep and bear arms in defiance
of your own State's Constitution and
your uh your Federal Constitution our
Federal Constitution
so we this is the story that we uh we
got sheriff in New Mexico's most
populous County rejects Governor's gun
ban calling it unconstitutional reject
because what does that really mean the
current rumor that we're hearing and I
think I have it here from the paper
I have I I don't know what this this uh
publication is I'm not familiar with it
uh I don't know how accurate this is all
I know is this is being circulated it
may or may not be true take it with a
grain of salt however in it
Carolyn's they say that they they
reached out it's uh the paper in
Albuquerque that's what's called the
paper reached out to Carolyn Sweeney a
Luhan Grisham spokeswoman who said the
order is being enforced and citations
will be forthcoming from the state
police to ensure officer safety we will
not be providing additional details at
this time so I'm wondering if the move
they make is to pull up videos of people
who were openly carrying and then
privately go after them so imagine this
someone goes to the rally and they're
openly caring legally but the governor
has issued a decree they're on camera
facial recognition whatever they know
who the person is they issue a warrant
for their arrest and under what you know
under what law or whatever it's not
going to be for open carrying open
carrying there's going to be some
violation like Defiance of Public Health
Emergency section whatever the cops are
going to show up to the guy's house and
say we have a warrant for your arrest
for you know Defiance of executive order
and list a bunch of charges none of
which will be having a gun
the person is going to be like are we
talking about and the cop's going to say
listen man I don't know who you are I
don't know what you did I know you're
under arrest so while many people are
saying the cops won't enforce this cops
will defy it I'm like yeah but what
happens when some random 28 year old cop
is told we got a warrant for a guy on
disorderly conduct felony disorderly on
state grounds and he goes sounds good to
me they're gonna start getting arrested
but we'll see I'm glad to see that
people are standing up to this it's it's
it's it's blowing up in the in the
governor's face Democrats are angry
about it but you know well it should go
it should blow up in the governor's face
this is another one of these lead
through crisis situations we saw this
with Biden we saw this Kamala Harris was
talking about this they were listing off
you know this was pre-covet even they
were listing off
um Public Health emergencies they were
talking about climate change Public
Health Emergency racism then they threw
covet into the mix they threw guns into
the mix and it's like you were saying
like as soon as you declare something a
public health emergency they start
suspending all of our civil liberties
and you remember even during covid you
had sheriffs and police officers saying
that they were not going to enforce
lockdown orders but people were getting
arrested anyway you know there's still
people who get who who have been charged
with that stuff and been prosecuted and
that stuff stands yeah and I would say I
love two-way people like this idea that
there's just a bunch of them like openly
carrying guns and everything is fine
like you're not hearing anything about
any violence that came out of this rally
I think it's such an interesting display
because uh if the government of New
Mexico is taking such a drastic and
expansive interpretation of Public
Health Emergency it's cool to see them
say well we're just going to protest and
demonstrate publicly rather rather than
say well I'm scared of what will happen
I think that's uh the sort of only uh I
don't know white pill in this situation
the other thing too though is remember
in um in Lansing Michigan in April 2020
you had a lot of people showing up at
the Capitol say saying we are opposed to
lockdown orders we're not going to do
this anymore they went into the Capitol
and they were called White supremacists
you know these people are going to get
called names and the other thing too is
like even if they're out there today and
the sheriff says oh maybe we're not
going to prosecute you don't know like
they could come to your door in two
months there's people now getting
arrested for 9 11. they've arrested over
1200 people for that you don't even know
9 11. whatever it is
that is obnoxious to use dates they
actually there's only a couple of people
who were arrested now for 9 11 and they
haven't been prosecuted so they're still
hanging out in Guantanamo and
prosecutors are looking at plea deals
for those people but don't worry we got
all of the January we have 9 11 in my
head because it's my birthday I
apologize I've heard stories of people
who are on the capitol on the capitol
grounds
that were that nothing ever happened
right so like a year ago there were
stories people would say was like oh I
knew someone who was at that rally and
they were walking around the grass but
they never got charged arrested I
thought they'll show up at your house
well and then they just arrested Owen
Shroyer uh they had arrested tomorrow
they're trying to sentence him to like
120 days he didn't go into the capital
he was hanging out outside and part of
the thing and yelling and yelling
generic
anti-establishment like revolutionary
commentary and then the sentencing well
I said I think it's a death yeah and so
Democrats were tyrants I mean yeah
they also reference things that he said
on air yeah I mean
after yeah if you read the the statement
from the doj they say in the months
leading up and they said he he made
January 6th I mean they are trying to
make another person they're pinning this
on uh and you know rightly so his
attorney is responded with uh you are
trying to use to violate his Free Speech
rights and to make this more than what
it is they also say you know he's been
on pre-tr like it's supervised pre-trial
uh supervision for the last two years so
surely he shouldn't have to also go to
jail but this is what people in New
Mexico need to think about as well one I
think it's good that people are
Democrats are on board with rejecting
the governor's decree so they're
probably these people who protested
probably gonna be totally safe
if these rumors are true
it's going to get scary because it's not
going to be a cop showing up saying you
you defied the governor's order and
carried a weapon you're under arrest and
then the person films themselves they're
like look what's happening now it's
going to be like you have you have a
bench warrant for your arrest why what
did I do that's for the court I don't
know man all I know is I got I'm told
you got a warrant and you're coming with
me I've been rereading the trial the
Kafka novel and this guy gets arrested
and he gets put on trial and they never
tell him the charges right they never
tell him what he did wrong and he's
trying to navigate the court and figure
things out and trying to like understand
how he's being treated uh trying to
navigate having a job he doesn't want to
tell anybody that this is happening to
him because he's embarrassed and he's
ashamed every everywhere he looks and
the more he the more he digs into his
trial and what's going on the more he
realizes that like literally everyone is
against him everyone has been spying on
him this whole time
um
and I it just has seemed uh like the
exact right time to reread the trial and
the more I listen to it because I've
been doing it on audiobooks The More I
listen to it I'm just like Tang like
Kafka knew what he was talking about
exactly we're looking at this now what
was his political Kafka what year what
country was he from he was from the
Czech Republic then Czechoslovakia he
lived in Prague he was basically an
insurance clerk who was writing on the
side
um I don't know what his political
leanings were he was essentially
anti-authoritarian
was he during the Soviet era it was it
was when was he writing what was it like
Franz Kafka 30 1880 1880 1925. there you
go Western he's alive he's only 40. yeah
I was reading him in high school
um
because I was really intrigued by a
couple of his stories metamorphosis and
The Hunger Artist were the ones that
really I was like whoa what's that about
and then the castle but
um but yeah he was anti-authoritarian
and if you look at his work it's just
like this crushing State and there you
are just this individual trying to have
an existence you know and in many cases
just a quiet existence without being
bothered without being any you know in
trouble at all without having anybody
come at you and it's just the state
swirls around you eats you up and
destroys you I I think a lot of people
have this uh misunderstanding about how
the system works when it's working
against you I think a lot of people
especially people watch the show
probably get it but I feel like the
average person they assume that if you
do something wrong you know the cops
show up and they say you do something
wrong they don't realize that sometimes
you're in the wrong place at the wrong
time and you get arrested for no reason
there's a guy to Occupy Wall Street who
this is a hilarious Story by the way he
is a middle-aged guy wearing a suit with
gray hair
and he is inside a bodega Frozen don't
know a corner store buying an orange I
think was a Fanta
the police use that orange kettling that
they call it to wrap around protesters
so to stop people from leaving when they
say that's an unlawful assembly and
you're all under arrest the cops go from
one side of the building and they make a
half moon around all these people and
the door and the guy walks out of the
convenience store drinking his orange
Fanta on break from work and he's
confused like what's going on why am I
in this thing he can't go back inside
they're like no you can't come in and
then he goes to the cop and says hey I
was just in the store buying a drink and
they're like shut your mouth and he's
like I'm not a protester I'm just a guy
on break I'm drinking they're like
you're under arrest shut your mouth
most the cops holding holding the the
the the the netting won't say anything
he has a supervisor they ignore him he
got arrested he got arrested for
literally drinking an orange Fanta
because he walked out of a store into
the area they had corralled and the
police had anyone inside this is under
arrest even though they got some guy who
was just drinking a soda doesn't matter
and so he goes to jail he can't tell his
work what happened and all I know this
is what I was told right
uh he was at a meeting in the city
screaming at the top of his lungs to the
police about what they had done to him
and the cops just like we literally do
not care what you think it's a it's a
city of millions of people and you are
one guy with no Authority and no power
so you can shut your mouth you're
meaningless they didn't say that
literally but that's what they that's
basically it and they just paid off BLM
protesters who were torching cop cars
well there's millions of occupies yeah I
know but they just did this they paid
off protest they're not protesters
they're like militant BLM Riders they
paid them off millions of dollars
there's a lot of stories like that where
the police arrest random people there
was a guy named Alex Arbuckle who was
taking pictures of Occupy Wall Street
he's standing on the sidewalk when the
protesters get you know circled or
whatever and a cop walks up to him while
he's not part of the protest and on the
sidewalk away from the protest and
arrests him
he was a different officer was told to
sign for the arrest and fabricate a
statement as to why he should be
arrested and the fabricated statement
was that he was obstructing the roadway
like all the other protesters the funny
thing is this guy went down there to
tell the police's side of the story on
the protests because he felt it wasn't
being accurately portrayed and uh I was
live streaming everything that had at
the time
and I filmed the illegal arrest the
officer who lied under oath never got
any accountability never two officers
fabricated the charges against him and
this guy cold wake-up call the cops just
made it up I think the one of the
problems we faced with a lot of the with
a lot of what's going on with tyranny is
is density uh like a lot of the problems
that emerge that we complain about in
terms of weird Progressive cult-like
behavior is just density of cities and
then an inability for people to come
like how how you deal with 300 violent
protesters throwing bottles into rocks
at cops
well like this is a group of people
dudes we gotta arrest them uh-oh there
were two guys in there who were wrongly
roped in what do you do do you then go
through it like can we do like what do
you do check all the phones for videos
of everyone so they just say we don't
care yeah I think the problems of
corruption at the top is due to density
too because when you know everybody
you're working with all 60 of your your
people you have a personal relationship
with everybody you can make sure that
everyone's needs are met that if there's
a problem with one of them it can be uh
it can be you know dealt with but if
there's 300 million people that you're
trying to govern it just becomes numbers
man I mean that's what Luan Grisham is
doing too right she's saying anyone who
is interested in having a gun is
potentially dangerous and therefore I'm
going to uh carry this out on all
citizens I mean it's a complete
overreach and that's similar to the
position the cops take we've decided
there's a crisis and so we don't care
about the Nuance let's think about it
this way
the the order that was given by Grisham
is that if there's like something like a
thousand deaths or it's like some
capacity like if there's a number of
deaths related to guns at this number
you can't have a gun there which
basically is Albuquerque and and
Bernalillo so think about it this way
for let's say for every 100 citizens you
have every year there's one gun murder
that's a lot yeah okay but hold on let's
let's say that there is a town of 100
people and every year one person dies in
a shooting
talking but one murder is not going to
shock the minds of every single of of of
the Town they're going to be Iceland
they have like four murders a year and
as a substantially less people so the
issue is
when if if it's what I have to talk
about with the uh the scaling problem if
one per let's say 0.1 of your population
is killed in a gun in a in by violence
every year so let's say for every
thousand people one person dies No One's
Gonna blame guns they're gonna say this
murder is unconscionable now let's say
you have a million people okay now all
of a sudden you've got what a ten
thousand I'm gonna do my math wrong or a
thousand
you have a thousand deaths now you ban
guns because it's a gun problem a
thousand people dying is terrifying even
though it's the same proportionality so
this is the problem of mass density in
these cities it may be that people are
dying probably dying at lower rates
percentage-wise due to gun violence than
ever before but there's more gun deaths
than ever before there's more people and
more guns and more media right in the
hands of the mother of the kid that was
killed or the cousin of the guy that got
shot like back in the day you'd get a
news report about it maybe well so
here's the other thing like police
blotter I remember I always check the
police block now you get viral Twitter
posts but even a million people see and
stuff that freaks people out over and
over and pre-2000 if someone got shot
they're gonna die you your chances of
getting paramedics there you're running
to find a pay phone when I was a
teenager I watched a woman have some
kind of stroke and I'm 16 no cell phones
I mean people at cell phones at the time
like but
right I had to run into a bank and it
was like I run into a bank and I was
like I need help and there's a guy
speaking he was excuse me we're in the
middle of me I'm like a lady just
collapsed and then they they'd stand up
and then they call 9-1-1 or whatever but
like if I had a cell phone like if it's
today I went someone fall I stole my
phone right away right so the the you
know but that means you probably have
more people dying like in the 90s and
you could probably see you know
homicides going down you actually can
because of cell phones but now because
we have more and more people she's
justifying the amount of people as the
reason why to ban guns but also you know
criminals aren't going to care they're
going to carry guns anyway as always
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time